[Music]
so
um
hi
welcome to the table
oh my goodness how are you guys doing
oh my goodness it's it's the fourth of
july
i know that it is very warm outside it's
kind of
it's kind of nutty and we are thrilled
that um you guys are here to join us and
everything like that um so we are kind
of a little different we'll kind of get
into more of the differences
later on
[Laughter]
so one of the differences is that right
now i'm kind of little off on our
announcements other than i will say um
if you want to kind of join the
fireworks that are happening later on
this evening um obviously as you guys
kind of walked in you kind of saw lucky
all the different vendors and different
things they have going on but uh city of
saxi is doing um some fireworks uh
displays tonight um and roughly's gonna
start about nine o'clock you know this
that whole sundown thing can't really
quite calculate exactly when the
fireworks is going to start but that's
kind of roughly when that's going to
begin so of course it's a family family
family event there's going to be hot
dogs and
sodas to purchase and things like that
so of course
you guys are welcome to participate and
join in that
so
with that being said i will just kind of
do a quick reminder that we are just um
brett's kind of off ish
um this um this this month we're giving
him a break
kind of a thing he does a lot for our
community
and things like that so we're kind of
giving him a little break except for
today
he's going to be here
in spirit we'll kind of get into that a
little bit more in details later on but
today
we're but this month we're kind of
giving him a little bit of a break so um
uh but we're looking forward to some of
the things that we are going to have for
a lined up for speakers and things like
that for the rest of this month so most
definitely stick around um yeah for
months of july because um we've got some
really amazing people kind of lined up
to
lead us for the next several weeks
so with that being said
i'm going to start off with a prayer
we'll get started with
um
worship
lord thank you so much for bringing us
here together
thank you for
um just this time this opportunity
um
thank you for just being around being
able to be with family because i know
it's been it's the summer um we get to
just be able to experience things that
we don't normally get experience during
the course of the year
and then i just pray that you just be
with us specifically tonight as we are
getting ready to worship
i pray that you just open up our hearts
our minds to the things that you want us
to hear
from you
uh the things are in our lives that we
are just wrestling with that we're
struggling with that we're just carrying
with us i pray that
this is a space
where we know that we can just find
some peace
i pray you just be with us tonight
christ and i pray amen
welcome everyone
we're really glad you're here we're
going to invite you to stand even though
we're going to be sitting
um
so
yeah
um yeah
we uh working to do something a little
bit different tonight um
uh mindy is off today so she asked me to
uh
really all of us to lead in her place
and so this is going to be a very
relaxed acoustic set feel free to stand
if you feel like you need to sit and
just
let god speak to you
you go for it that's what we're here for
[Music]
through every battle
through every heartbreak
through every circumstance
i believe that you are my fortress
oh you are my portion
you are my hiding
i place
you are the way
the truth
the life
i believe you are the way
the truth
the life
i believe you are
[Music]
through every blessing
through every promise
through every breath i take
i believe that you are provider
you are protector
you are the one i love
i believe you are
the way
the
truth i believe
you are
the way
the truth
the life
i believe you are
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
and you meet me here today
mercies that are new
and all my fears and doubts
they can all come to
because they can't stay long
when i'm here with you
it's a new horizon
and i'm set on you
[Music]
because they can't stay
the truth
[Music]
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
[Music]
i believe you are it's a new horizon
now i'm set on you
and you meet me here today
mercies that are new
and all my fears and doubts
they can all come true
because they can't stay long when i
believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
i believe you are
the way
the truth
the life
[Music]
all right kiddos you can head on out
easy
so this time we're going to move into
our prayers of the people
so we're going to read this prayer
together and then there'll be a time
for you to say within the space a name
or a situation that you want us all to
pray for and those of you are online
you can do that in the comments section
but let's pray this together
for the city of saxi texas
and for every city and community and all
of those who live in him
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow
and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering we
pray to you
for the poor
and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute
for the prisoners and the captives
and for all who remember and care for
them we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and you hear us
so we lift these names and situations up
to you
please pray for those dealing with
physical and mental health issues
and please lift up the gandies in prayer
so
for the names and moments
we have spoken aloud and for those we
have kept in our hearts
we pray to you that they may have life
and light
healing and hope
peace and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
you give life
you are love
you bring light
to
the
darkness you give hope
you restore
every heart that is
[Music]
it's your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise
pour out our praise it's your breath
in our alarms
so we pour out our praise
[Music]
you give life
you are love
you bring light
to
the darkness you give hope
you restore
every heart that is
it's your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise pour out our
praise it's your breath
in our lungs so we pour out our praise
to you only
and great are you
great are you
[Music]
seeing all the earth
and all the
earth will shout your praise our hearts
will cry these bones will sing
great
[Music]
and all the earth will shout your praise
our hearts will cry these bones will
sing
great are
you lord
[Music]
will shout your praise our hearts will
cry these bones will sing
great are
you
and all the earth will shout your praise
our hearts will cry these bones will
sing
in grace
[Music]
it's your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise pour out our
praises your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise to you only
it's your breath
in our lungs so we pour out our praise
pour out our praises your bread
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise to you
[Music]
and great are you lord
sing that again
it's your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise
pour out our praise it's your breath
in our laws
so we pour out our praise to you only
it's your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise
pour out our praise it's your breath
in our lungs
so we pour out our praise to you only
[Music]
and great are
just yesterday i was uh
reading in psalm 139
and there's this part in psalm 139 where
david is is saying like where can i go
from your presence if i make my
bed and if i go to the heavens you're
there if i make my bed in the depths
you're there
if i go to the far side of the sea
you're there waiting for me
and it just kind of reminded me like
brett a few weeks ago he talked about
how it's kind of strange when we say we
invite god into the room or whatever
because god's already here
you can't really invite someone who's
already in the room
but just like that last song said like
our very breath is a gift from god
that's god's presence already with us
we're just becoming more and more aware
of it
there's nothing worth more
it could ever come close
nothing can compare
your our living hope
your
presence lord
i've tasted and seen
of the sweetest of loves
when my heart becomes free
and my shame is
[Music]
this place and fill
your glory
god is
[Music]
your presence
there's nothing worth more
that could ever come close
nothing can compare
[Music]
your presence
and i've tasted and
[Music]
seen my heart becomes free
and my shame is undone
[Music]
in your presence
this place
[Music]
presents
stop it
[Music]
let us become
more aware
of your presence
let us
experience the glory of your goodness
let us become
more aware of your presence
let us
experience the glory of your goodness
let us become
more aware of your presence
let us
experience the glory of your goodness
let us become
more aware of your presence
let us experience
the glory of your goodness
[Music]
yes holy
spirit you are well
come here
come flood this place and fill the
atmosphere
your glory
god is what our hearts long for
to be
overcome
by your presence
lord
[Music]
your
presence lord
your presence
[Music]
it's all around your presence
we don't have to ask for your
[Music]
it's a presence
your presence
lord
your
presence lord
your presence
lord
[Music]
your presence
god we are deeply grateful
that your presence is always with us
god it is a gift it's not something we
have to beg for
you're with us on our best days
you're with us on our darkest days
sometimes when it feels like you're not
here it's actually that you're so close
we just can't see you
but we can trust that
you are always near
continue to draw us near jesus
we ask this in your holy and precious
name
amen
you guys can have a seat and say hi to
the people around you
to hybrid church
so
so fred has unfortunately tested
positive for a coved and so just wanted
to be completely safe for everyone in
the room um we are going to be doing him
virtually so um so we are like i said
welcome to hybrid church
[Laughter]
all right
and everything like that so um but yes
he's going to be on the screens
through the duration of the service he
will also be um leading us also with um
our invitation to the community um to
the table to the community so everything
else is going to be exactly the same as
it normally is but just wanted to kind
of give you guys a heads up that we are
doing an interesting hybrid version of
uh not completely virtual not completely
in person but we're glad that we're glad
that we're able to do this quite frankly
i mean we're in a good spot to be able
to provide even this level of um
interaction so anyway so with that being
said take it away brad
awesome all right y'all
well obviously this i would rather be
there in person but um you know what
it is what it is and we thought of
having someone read um my manuscript but
it's like okay let me just let's just do
it this way this seemed this even better
so um thank you to gary and the whole
tech team
um and others who have helped pull all
this off so
um
well welcome everyone and if there's
anyone new or visiting with us either
online or in person uh welcome to you
and um
i also but before i get into the series
i want to do a quick check my texts make
sure they're not like brett we can't
hear a word you're saying
no okay i think we're
i think we're good
um
so all right no comments all right i
think we're good hopefully you all can
hear me and i'm not just speaking to
myself for the next 20 minutes
so all right so our series um is titled
uh hearing god a listening
life
and um basically our big idea for this
series has has been that while of course
god can speak in the loud and the
remarkable and the miraculous you know
audible voice type thing uh most of the
time that is not how it happens uh which
can be quite confusing when people are
talking about oh the lord told me this
you know um and so the reality is most
of the time god um whispers to us in
uh as we looked at last week
the inmost in most depths of our being
as the still small voice so um with that
in mind the title of my message tonight
is hearing god in community which may
sound a little bit the opposite of you
know in inward um and yet there's still
a discernment process of when someone
speaks to us that does happen in
internally which we'll we'll get into
later so um our primary text
from the scriptures is a story from
exodus 18 which we're not going to read
quite yet i want to give a little
context a little background on this
so
basically for those not familiar with
the book of exodus uh the the great i
mean probably the greatest leader in
jewish history um one of the greatest
prophets moses has now led the people of
god out of egypt
which is why the title of the book is
exodus
and so the people are journeying through
the wilderness on their way to the land
that god has promised to them with moses
as their leader now it seems though at
some point in maybe the like plagues of
egypt or something moses at some point
had sent his wife and his two sons away
uh to live with his father-in-law um
named jethro um
but now that moses is in the wilderness
you know they're out of egypt uh he
receives a surprise visit his wife
zipporah and his two sons gershom and
eliezer are back and along for the visit
is his father-in-law jethro so moses
spends that first evening
telling all the stories telling jethro
and all the family uh just the
remarkable stories of their exodus uh
jethro is of course quite overjoyed um
so they all i'm guessing it was a late
night uh they wake up the next morning
so we pick up the story there in verse
13 of exodus chapter 18.
the next day moses took his seat to
serve as judge for the people and they
stood around him from morning till
evening when his father-in-law saw all
that moses was doing for the people he
said what is this you are doing for the
people why do you alone sit as judge
while these people stand around you from
morning
till evening
moses answered him
because the people come to me to seek
god's will whenever they have a dispute
it is brought to me and i decide between
the parties and inform them of god's
decrees and instructions
moses father-in-law replied what you're
doing is not good verse 18 you and these
people who come to you will only wear
yourselves out the work is too heavy for
you you cannot handle it alone
listen now to me and i will give you
some advice and may god be with you you
must be the people's representative
before god and bring their disputes to
him
teach them his decrees and instructions
show them the way they are to live and
how they are to behave but select
capable men from all the people men who
fear god trustworthy men who hate
dishonest gain and appoint them as
officials over thousands hundreds
fifties and tens have them serve as
judges for the people at all times but
have them bring every difficult case to
you the simple cases they can decide
themselves that will make your load
lighter because they will share it with
you if you do this and god so commands
you will be able to stand the strain and
all these people will go home satisfied
moses listened to his father-in-law and
did everything he said all right so one
of the reasons i
love this story as an example of god
speaking through others
is precisely because it is not a
thus saith the lord type story
this is not a moment where jethro begins
trembling in the spirit he places his
hands upon moses head and declares i
have a word from god for you brother
and
you know i'm not sure of your background
perhaps for some of you you kind of
believe like god's never spoken to me
through others because
it has not come packaged in that
that way um but just as i've done
throughout the series what i want to do
tonight is normalize the notion of
hearing from god through other people i
want us to realize god is continually
speaking leading teaching and guiding
my
so my guess is that god is speaking to
you through other people many times a
day probably
you just don't think of it as a word
from god again as we've been talking
about throughout the series it's because
we're looking for like the big thing
uh when it's often um you know just just
not that way um now
you might say
how can that be
uh well think of it like this
is there
some word of love
that someone can speak over you
that is somehow separate from the god
who is love
is there some encouragement
that a person could impart that is not
always already deeply formed by the god
who is for you
is there some wisdom a person could
offer you that is somehow
separate
from the source of all wisdom
aka
god
no
no whatever is good whatever is lovely
whatever is encouraging uplifting or
life-giving whatever sets you on a new
path of hope and healing even though it
comes through another person oh dear
ones it is god
all the way down
you're likely having an experience of
god you're likely receiving a word from
god
now why do i say
likely
instead of you are and i know it um well
because discernment on your part is
needed as jesus said you'll know a tree
by its fruit and similarly you'll know a
word from god by its results in your
life does the word does it tear you down
does it make you feel small
does it encourage that which is worst in
you
well then honestly if that's the case i
don't care if the person said thus saith
the lord
it was not the spirit of christ the
spirit of faith hope and love which was
speaking to you um
however as i named earlier
does the word bring life
does it uplift
does it encourage or challenge you in a
way that perhaps stings in the moment
but also resonates with you as the truth
if that's the case well my goodness like
how could that be somehow separate from
god
a few uh weeks ago
i had a bit of i'm not sure of what to
call it like
it was kind of a freak out um
an emotional kind of freakout but
honestly it was but it was good like it
wasn't just me losing it it was like i
was kind of having um
a bit of a vulnerable moment i've
learned this about myself you know that
like okay it's better to
like at least me enneagram five
intj on the myers-briggs like i just
kind of want to always be in control and
in control of um my whole way of being
and so it's like if something's if i'm
feeling something strongly i'll just
hold off forever on sharing it usually
too long so i've kind of learned it's
better to just come out with it you know
so basically ensure i want to get a lot
of detail but there was a situation and
it just stirred up
all of the feelings in me
and as we talked about last week
challenging feelings not negative just
challenging ones uh there was what was
in there there was some fear
um
i just i felt small and insecure
uh but most of all afraid just fearful
and so i was processing all of this i
was talking with um right there in my
kitchen around a little bar with um
maggie
my wife and mindy my sister-in-law
and the situation related a little bit
more to my sister-in-law so i was like
sharing with her you know just kind of
pouring out my fears and just being but
being really honest and and kind of had
this like what moment and she was on his
back she was like had her own thoughts
too and um we weren't like fighting it
wasn't like ah you know but it was like
we were we were both having to be honest
with each other you know and it was a
little bit emotional it was just it was
challenging it was really challenging um
but i spoke she she heard me and i think
she could see that like i was
really struggling and so she just walked
over to me
and she gave me this big hug and she
said
brett
you
are
loved
you
are enough
don't be afraid
and i swear to you in that moment it was
the very
word
of god to me
father richard rohr
the catholic theologian he said this if
something comes toward you with grace
and can pass through you and toward
others with grace you can trust it as
the voice of god
roar continues one holy man who recently
came to visit me put it this way we must
listen to what is supporting us we must
listen to what is encouraging us we must
listen to what is urging us we must
listen to what is alive in us
church what is supporting you
what is encouraging you what is urging
you what is challenging you what is
bringing you alive
it
even if it's coming through others
that's it god is speaking
god is speaking i love that that roar
here he chose the word grace the opening
line if something comes toward you with
grace can pass through you and toward
others with grace i love that he chose
that word grace i i think he's referring
to um how
a thing how a word
how it comes to you
um is it graceful
is it peaceful
is it a word might be non-anxious
in other words when you receive a word
or perspective or wisdom
from someone and it is like a gentle
gift
and then that you can receive that and
in fact maybe even pass it along to
someone else like that whole process
that is a god moment
i want to come back to our exodus story
because i think moses encounter
with his father-in-law i think this was
a grace moment
i think it was a god moment i think it's
just incredibly instructive in um in
several aspects so i'm going to give you
um a few things tonight three principles
of hearing from god through others
from exodus 18. so principle number one
uh god's word to us from others
often comes from older more mature
people
notice
that it was not uh moses peers who spoke
to him
it was not his buddies
verse 14 when his father-in-law saw all
that moses was doing for the people he
said
what is this you're doing for the people
now
why would this be
um
yes i think it's partly because often
older folks have just indeed had more
time to walk with god
and thus can be just more attuned to um
god's voice to her voice but i i think
um it's also
that older folks um tend to be less
anxious
just in general
and thus
more tuned into the truth
um if you're a note taker you can jot
this down few things prevent us from
hearing god more than our own anxiety
can i get an amen
i have no idea if anyone just said i
hope i hope someone said it then
it's um
you know i think of anxiety it's like
static in a radio signal
for you old-timers still listen to radio
the kids are like radio but you know
radio you're trying to tune it in it's
just like that crackly sound and i think
that's sort of like the equivalent of
anxiety in our life it's just it's just
that white noise it's just static and
we're trying to see clearly and discern
things and hear god clearly but anxiety
is like oh gosh and and so i think this
is one reason we need to hear from god
through others
um there's actually a popular idea
you know right now
very
popular in just kind of all of
protestantism um but in christian in
general but um it's this idea of i don't
need church
i don't need the church
um you know jesus is great but church
are she's people you know um i think
that is a tremendous mistake and
actually at least partly for this reason
because we just get lost in our own
little worlds we can't and we
uh we can't hear clearly we can't see
clearly and we often need a word from
god through others and so one good thing
coming back to kind of my theme here one
good thing about a mature older people
is um
that they have seen a lot of life
and they know and they trust that god
will bring them through
and so because of this they're just flat
out less anxious
and can see some things discern some
things speak plainly to us so okay so
what's the takeaway here um if you don't
have someone like this find an older
trusted friend
in your life
a mentor in like get with them get
coffee have a meal once a month
something and like get their perspective
and honestly do what they say
instead of always trusting your anxious
brain
my laugh turns into an actual god i am
like okay
okay now having said that
there is a counterbalance um to this
point i just made so that leads us to
our second principle
god's word to us from others should not
be forced or insisted upon by them
in other words if someone says well god
told me to tell you
fill the blank and you must do it
oh
red flag tremendous red flag it is
almost always someone manipulating you
um
it might also be a sign of the
beginnings of spiritual abuse
notice um that jethro offered his
perspective and then said this in verse
if you do this right so in other words
you follow my advice and god so commands
it's a key line if you do this and god
so commands
i think you'll be able to stand the
strain and all these people will go home
satisfied can you see there how jethro
is
uh or was offering his perspective
but then added moses look you need to do
your own business with god
you need to discern is if this is the
thing god is actually commanding you to
do because frankly it may not be
again look for the fruit of the word
does it uplift you does it inspire does
it challenge you in a good way does it
energize or when you receive the word
does it just drain the life out of you
is it like nothing but sheer
discouragement
um or if the word is predictive like
does it come true don't don't just
assume
i um i think it was the spring of
um so this was before we started the
table
i was at a christian a little kind of
local conference it wasn't like a mega
conference but a little local conference
christian conference and it had it's
kind of a little charismatic pentecostal
influence
and so um during the lunch one day
i was eating with a young man who i just
barely knew but we had some like mutual
acquaintances so he was a super nice he
was he was quirky but he was super nice
and suddenly he looked at me and he said
i think i have a word from god for you
do you mind if i share it to which i
replied
sure
and so he closed his eyes
and he extended his hand
toward me
and he said
fun
fun fun fun
fun fun fun fun fun
[Laughter]
it was
the strangest word from god he was like
the word was fun i was like yeah i
picked up on that um and
so
i mean we kind of went on from there it
was a fascinating word from god i mean
honestly i really hoped it would be true
i was like yeah okay yes i received this
word
i want to have fun in my life and enjoy
myself um so i kind of had that word
like in the back of my mind for the next
you know months and years or so and i
was kind of just wondering like huh what
was that about and will it you know kind
of come true or like will this be my
most fun of
months or years or something you know
and um
truth be told
no
no it was one of the most challenging
two-year windows of my life
like we had um we had stuff to work
through from our previous church
community um i ultimately had to resign
from that position
then we started the um the table which
was fun but also like just a ton of work
i wouldn't necessarily describe it as
just fun fun fun but you know i don't
know
and then of course right after that
covet hit um
and now here i am uh what
four three or four years after that and
now i have coveted um it's not no um
okay so i will say it was kind of
hilarious throughout this time i could
look at maggie when we were just really
going through it and i would just look
because i told her of course about this
work and i would just say fun
fun fun
fun fun fun
so okay so the question is was that a
word from god
you know i mean i i think that gentleman
i think it was super well intentioned i
don't think so um i mean maybe maybe i
missed it maybe there was some aspect or
something i didn't tune into but um the
point is just because someone says thus
saith the lord or i just really feel
strongly you need to do this i really
think this might be god you know
just because they're doing that does not
mean you should buy it and in fact the
more they pressure you which did this
man's um credit he didn't pressure me he
very much much was like hey this
resonates great if not a big deal you
know um and that's how people should be
talking with you that's how people
should be sharing with you um
discernment is always needed all right
principle number three
god's word to us from others often
reveals our blind spots
one thing that is so fascinating about
this story
is that and well frankly that it's about
moses
again as i said earlier moses was one of
the greatest prophets who ever lived god
spoke to moses at times
audibly none of this still small voice
discerning what god's saying no no like
audibly with his ears moses was like the
pope and the president
all wrapped up in one person
and yet
even moses needed community
needed wisdom
needed a word from god that came to him
from others
why
well honestly because
even moses was a human being
and even moses was doing dumb things
but here's the key it was dumb things
that he could not see
because
he was moses
because he was himself jethro asked in
verse 14
why do you alone sit as judge while all
these people stand around you from
morning till evening moses answered him
because the people came to me or come to
me to see god's will like in other words
moses is like why do i do this well
because the people ask me to seems
logical and jethro's like
uh nope that's real dumb
uh let's put it like this the one thing
you cannot give yourself is outside
perspective
the one thing you cannot give yourself
is outside perspective even moses
needed others how much more you and i
if you think you are normal
sane
mature and wise
friend i hate to break it to you you
lack an honest community around you
telling you the truth
you are you are a little bit delusional
because the truth is
you are riddled with blind spots
and and this is why i really believe the
only thing worse
than having a group of lovingly
difficult people in your life
continually pointing out your blind
spots the only thing worse than that
is not
having a group of lovingly difficult
people in your life
continually
in love
but continually pointing out your blind
spots just like i said last week trust
me your kids
wish you had someone like that in your
life
your partner wishes you had someone like
that in your life
your friends wish you had given them
permission
to speak like that into your life
so church let's let's do it
let's be that community to one another
um now how do we do that here at the
table we do that primarily through
meetups
um and and through sharing vulnerably at
those meetups so um
will that be messy oh for sure
but will we also receive
words from god that come to us like
god's grace yes
absolutely absolutely um so if you're
interested in meetups you can reach out
to me
many of you most of you have my number
or
um just reach out via our church website
tablets.org we'd love to just be in
touch with you and help you get
connected to a meetup so
um as we come to the table of the lord
today
as we
um take in
the body
of christ
symbolizing the in the bread and the
blood of christ symbolize and the wine
notice that we do this not as
autonomous isolated individuals
notice that we come together
as a community we participate as the
body of christ we come forward as people
in need
as as broken people as people with blind
spots as people in need of a word from
god that we cannot give ourselves
um
and there is something beautiful about
that so i pray today that as you come
forward to receive communion um
that it would be a moment of connection
with god but also um with the people
around you
so
let me invite you to the table with this
celtic christian invitation
this is the table
not of the church but of the lord
and it's made ready for those who love
him and for those who want to love him
more so come
you who have much faith in you who have
little
you who have been here often and you who
have not been here long
you who have tried to follow and you who
have failed
come
come because it's the lord himself who
invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
love you all
[Music]
so
well i for one
hello check one two
anything
hello
can you hear me okay there we go
awkward
um
for one i feel really relieved that
brett looks so good on tv i mean he just
just pops
um
yeah
what a what a cool
cool way i the whole time like josh and
i every every point brett was making we
were like snapping because
it's just everything he was saying was
really hitting and
it fits so well with this song so we're
going to sing the song called build my
life
and
there's the chorus lyrics of this go
like this
holy there is no one like you
there is none beside you
you open up my eyes and wonder
and show me who you are and fill me with
your heart
and lead me in your love to those around
me
really this
this song is about community you
wouldn't find it in the community
section on
songs but um it really is about that
it's about god's love filling us up and
us worshiping and that flowing into
the people around us which is
us right
so if you want to stand you're welcome
if you want to sit and just
chill you're good with that too
worthy of every song we could ever sing
[Music]
worthy of all the praise we could ever
worthy of every breath we could ever be
[Music]
jesus the name above every other name
jesus the only one who could ever
worthy of every breath we could ever be
[Music]
there is
show me
who you are
[Music]
worthy of every song we can ever see
worthy
of every breath we can ever
[Music]
jesus
there is
[Music]
who you are
i will build my life
and i
will build my life
upon your love it is a firm
i
will put my trust in you
alone
and i will not
[Music]
it is
and i
will put my trust in you alone
[Music]
holy
there is no one like you
there is none beside you
open up my eyes and
wonder
show me
who you are and fill me
with your heart lead me
in your love to those
me
[Music]
thank you again worship team um again
glad that you guys are here um i mean
it's amazing that we're again able to do
what we're able to do today even given
uh brett's situation everything like
that
kind of it's really funny because it was
just when we were laughing or you can
tell we were kind of connecting with
what he was saying you can tell that you
know he just didn't know what was going
on
so i just would encourage you just like
if that meant something to y'all or just
touched you in some way um because he is
going to be gone for a while um at least
not physically coming to church every
single week if you might just shoot him
a message just let him know um and
everything like that just because again
it's kind of hard to when you're all
you're looking at is a camera and you're
like i hope this is sticking
you know you just don't know you have no
idea so just just kind of send a message
and just how much appreciate
his word that he did on this evening um
also just as a reminder we are um
uh partnering with uh pleasant valley
tonight so again as i mentioned before
you know hot dogs water uh sodas things
like that um if you want you guys want
to stick around that'd be fantastic and
great
and then i'm just going to sit you out
with this benediction and if you'd like
to receive that your and i can invite
you to stand
you can
open up your your hands if you'd like to
receive
so i just want you to know that you are
a child of god
you
are a child of god
and this is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
us yet to determine highs and lows and
everything in between
go
filled with the assurance that you were
loved
you were worthy and you were accepted
just as you are
and go
filled with god's holy spirit and the
desire to extend these same gifts
of grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with
amen
[Music]
show me
who you are
[Music]
there
is none beside
[Music]
show me
who you are
[Music]
me